foreign
you excited to catching big fish yeah
yeah I'm looking forward to a little you
and me Ty man this is gonna be awesome
[Music]
huh
take that one
your destination is on the right
good morning
[Music]
me and Tom are here in Atlantic Beach
North Carolina and I'm here with Captain
Jared with Tombstone Charters and it's
early in the morning and we are headed
out for some big game fishing the worlds
are oyster and we're excited to fish it
man
foreign
guys we went about an hour and a half
offshore to the Gulf Stream now you can
just watch the water temperature popping
up we're gonna start trolling for Mahi
Wahoo sailfish man we could hit all
sorts of fun things gotta tell you
something I really admire about my son
Tommy here he gets seasick on these open
water charters sometimes but he still
loves coming out on him
so what we're doing is we're trolling
with a little Bait fish called the Bali
who it looks like a little teeny tiny
swordfish each one of these Bali who is
rigged up beforehand got the eyes out a
little lead under the gills
got it tied in there it's a little bit
fidgety so you get them all tied up
ready to go before you start the day out
this one will just be popping across the
surface right this will be yeah just
subsurface uh say about 12 inches below
and he's hooking this Rod up to the
Outrigger and then using that little
pulley system to get the line out
further away from the boat so you can
fish more rods without them getting
tangled while you troll also allows you
to fish a bigger swath of water oh yeah
it's like a little popper yeah it's
designed to catch air in this little
concave head okay right now he's rigging
up some teasers a whole bunch of these
rubber squids and they don't even have
hooks on them the point is just to look
like a school of bait fish and tease the
fish and get them in to our actual Hooks
and bait when Tommy was little I used to
buy you big old teasers as a reward for
potty training so I had a big bucket of
little rubber squid and that was my
bribe
you feeling better Tom good
all right guys we're here at the end of
May in North Carolina and that's a great
time to catch big mahi-mahi or dolphin
fish and dolphin fish are notorious for
hanging out near any sort of floating
structure around weed beds or buoys or
debris anything that holds Bait fish so
we've jogged out here to the Gulf Stream
and we're looking for weed beds or
groups of weed that's floating in the
water and we're trolling up and down
those weed beds looking for some big
Mahi but we could also hit sailfish or
Wahoo Barracuda maybe a tuna does
anything good happen you can see little
schools of bait fish right there by the
weed
now the one downside to fishing near the
weed is you get a lot of weed snagged up
on your line so you have to constantly
jerk the line try to clear out the weeds
we got flying fish right there
seeing lots of flying fish going off
that's a good sign big patch of grass
right there let's see if there's
anything underneath it
over here oh
come on we got a good smack from a mahi
mahi right by that weed bed so we're
gonna rebate turn around try again where
there's one Monument there's often more
oh that's all that's left of our bait
dumb come on he's jumping oh
there he is
this one I saw him jump clean out of the
water buddy
you're about to land your first body man
good job keep going he's going oh hey
give me something right there oh there
we go
beautiful
all right there you go guys that's a
mahi mahi right there
colors on that thing I know
it's making big and nice big nice
oh
we got a good look at him he was big and
beautiful but hey you know when they get
away that makes them even bigger well
you're out fishing your dad look at you
man
believe you could do it too Dad
you feel a little better A lot better
some everything better Tommy's perking
up eating some breakfast it's got the
color back in his face
that's fatty right
right there this guy's just stripping
drag like there's no tomorrow
oh yes nice
I love Yellowfin and another one yeah
right there right there
I see some Joker oh he's a pretty shark
he's got buddy oh look at that
that is so awesome Tom what kind of
shark is it
oh nice
yeah yeah yeah you like that are you
happy yeah that's awesome all right
let's get it back in ready
that's cool slap my GoPro on the way out
Tiki guy yellowfin tuna my absolute
favorite fish to eat
glad to see you
oh what a wonderful fish all right all
right yeah put them in there and we'll
bleed them
so what he's doing is bleeding the tuna
when you get the blood out of the fish
while it's still fresh it makes the meat
taste a little better makes the meat
preserve better yeah your shark nibbled
that up good
yeah
Tom are you having a good trip
all right guys I got the whisker Seeker
catfishing carp series carbon fiber Rod
here and uh we're gonna see if we can't
catch some little Mahi on it it's gonna
be fun we're gonna start Trucking
to jump him out we can get little Mahi
to rise to it then we'll give him one
with a hook see if we can't catch a few
all right all these good guides work
together as teams and Jared's buddy over
here has been catching little mahi's
right by the boat so we're gonna join
them
all the money
oh here we go
oh there we go
all right
thank you
all right leave them in the water all
right you only got two
oh this is like my fourth one already
yeah there's Just Fish everywhere
oh this is crazy you can just see him
swarming down here he actually side
casting for my this is awesome
oh he came right at it yeah
got him yeah
we're sitting here catching these Mahi
mine we just saw a signal on the fish
finder means there's some trigger fish
down deep so we're gonna really quick
try to catch some of those too it looks
kind of like a heavy duty Sabiki rig
yeah kind of like a chicken rig
all right got an eight ounce lead a
little high low rig here we're gonna see
if we can't catch some trigger fish
you got him
hold on reel them in Tom
yeah
keep that run up yeah
yes they do buddy
buddy
oh yeah hold on
keep that right up yeah you go
restaurant
don't let go of my rod how can you do
the rest for me
we'll see yeah
definitely see what I'm saying
is that egg look at those teeth man
those are wicked wicked chompers
man look at that
[Music]
nice
how are you
oh yeah
oh
there we go
beautiful fish and they fight so hard I
never would have expected it
hello well I don't know about there you
go you're Tom you want to do it
out
oh yeah that's got a good look at that
foreign
we are doing the smorgasbord trip here
we are trying to catch as many different
species and experience as many different
things as we can and Tommy here really
really wants to catch a sailfish so
we're gonna troll our way back into
Shore a little bit and if we have a
little bit of time then we'll try for
some Snapper too
keep reeling real fast
keep going
all right that's good it's good
isn't he pretty
much
all right guys we've done a bit of
trolling but we're gonna switch gears
and try fishing for Vermilion Snapper
and some other bottom fish
[Music]
all right it looks like it's almost like
oh
what's the real what's the real buddy
oh we got a little double going on
something try to eat that looks fresh it
is hey
yeah all right
he's got a grunt oh bad mouth grunt it's
another coffee called red mouth grunts
see see the red mouth oh beautiful yeah
hold on
double Dante there we go
oh a little something different here
yeah so this is a bank bass a pretty I
like my baked bass
oh Tommy we're out of time man we gotta
head back so we gotta get back home and
cook these things up we got a ton of
fish to cook
oh man look at all them fish in that box
okay throw it right next to vine all
right that's actually pretty comfy
I caught two of them I got plenty of
bees oh hey I thought you were done
bleeding come on 26 26. I knew that like
I was still out for him then you got
five I'll tell you what I had a great
time catching those Mahi and trigger
fish on this little Rod if you guys want
to know more about this or you want to
buy one I'll put a link down in the
video description where you can get the
whisker Seeker catfish and carb series
rods
doing good doing good I thought you
gonna have to go swimming after
I'll tell you what guys there's a lot of
fillet knives on the market but every
time I come and see one of these guys
Flay fish they only use two brands of
fillet knives either a Dexter Russell or
above a knife
[Music]
there you go you got it look at that no
no that's for them uh
sorry this table says slippery they're
trying to steal some me rap
it was like I'm out of here
skin that's what the whole thing
we go nice lovely piece of Yellowfin
right there
needs to be
all right let's get this in the car
there we had an absolute blast thanks
for taking it listen if you guys are in
North Carolina and you want to do a trip
like this I'll put Captain Jared's
information with Tombstone charter down
in the video description below make sure
to check that out I'm gonna go do some
do some cooking yes sir thank you buddy
thank you have a great day all right
well now we got to drive six hours to
get home take the next left onto
Atlantic Beach Causeway all right me and
Tommy made it back to the house and now
we have got a load of fish to cook up
you excited yes so I've got a lot of
recipes planned I'm gonna do coconut
crusted mahi mahi with a mango reduction
I'm gonna do seared tuna steak and then
I'm gonna do tuna tacos with a tropical
fruit pico de gallo and avocado seared
the million Snapper and I'm gonna put
them on a toasted baguette with fresh
mozzarella basil and tomato but I've
never eaten Triggerfish before so I'm
gonna try cooking it in butter garlic
and rosemary and then kind of see what
happens
foreign
just let this sit and all the flavors
kind of mix
[Music]
es yeah
so good
is that a Lego or not
there we go
try it
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay take a little baguette a salted
tomato there you go a little Vermillion
Snapper on a baguette
oh not off the fork that you're serving
with okay so this is trigger fish and
it's supposed to taste like fresh
scallops because I love scallops one of
my favorites cookies it's crumbly no I
definitely got the scallop texture I'll
have it recorded that Mom is it's tuna
steak time we gotta steer some tuna
steak now
[Music]
doing this
[Music]
all right who's got a plate and an
appetite and that is good to hear all
right Amy what do you think it was
amazing I loved it all of it I couldn't
pick a favorite well I could this I like
this coconut thing you like the coconut
Bingo ball highlight it's amazing that's
good thank you what was your favorite
coconut mahi mahi mahi
yes Snapper's good good yeah oh I mean
it's all good but yeah trigger fish how
do you like take a fish okay
oh that was a lovely meal wasn't that
Becca that's great it was all good and I
don't really like fish I liked all of it
oh I like you thanks for watching guys
we hope you enjoyed that video as much
as we enjoyed eating that fish but if
you guys want to see more great videos
from the outdoor Boys YouTube channel
don't forget to click subscribe we put
out new videos every Saturday morning
nailed it
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor Boys YouTube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every Saturday morning and hit
that Bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching
[Music]